hello everyone welcome to our daily
homeroom uh for those of y'all uh this
is the first time you're joining us uh
this is a live stream we're doing on a
daily basis uh the catalyst was the
school closures that are now around the
world over 1.6 billion students around
the world are who normally would be
attending school are no longer doing
that at least for the time being and
what we see our responsibility as a
not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere it's always been in
service to teachers to parents to
students to make sure that folks can
have the best possible learning
experience and we realize that
especially in this time of school
closures it's our duty to step up and
figure out how we can support you the
the parents the students the teachers
out there how we can support school
districts and we're gonna have a really
robust conversation about that today uh
and i do wanna remind everyone we are a
not-for-profit organization and we are
we are able to do what we do because of
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in the position to
do so please think about donating to
khan academy
i want to give a special thanks to
several corporate partners who recently
stepped up to support these efforts to
keep khan academy going so that we can
keep everyone learning uh bank of
america at t google.org and novartis if
any of your corporations are thinking
about it
they should contact us as well we're
running at a deficit even before this
crisis hit and now our costs have gone
up dramatically to support our servers
which are now two and a half three x
normal load uh and all the other
programs that we would like to support
parents teachers and students with uh
and so our deficits are even larger so
if you can please support us
so with that
i'm i'm i'd like to introduce our guest
dr jesus jarrah who is the
superintendent at clark county school
district they are the fourth or fifth
largest school district in america this
is greater las vegas for those of y'all
who who might not be as familiar with
clark county and this is a i'm excited
about this conversation we've partnered
with dr jarrah actually at clark county
and in his previous world when he was
working in orlando but dr john maybe a
good place to start how are you and your
family doing first of all before we get
into the
yeah first before we get into the into
the world well first of all sal just
want to thank you for giving me the
opportunity to show a little bit uh
we're all safe and sound home you know i
got two college kids that have been
working online and you know doing some
of the online learning at both
institutions um so you know we're just
you know staying staying home
staying home for nevada as our governor
has continued to to remind our folks and
uh
learning a new world of education here
and also administrating uh the
administration really and helping our
our hard-working teachers and principals
from uh
from our our computer so um it's been a
little bit of a challenge in moving into
this direction but you know we're doing
well thank you
and and i mean just going into that a
little bit i've been curious as over the
last you know everyone's been fighting
their own crises over the past
four or five weeks but i'd love to hear
it from your perspective as a
superintendent of a large complex school
district
when
when did it get on your radar that that
something like this might happen and you
know as best as you can kind of play it
out
when did it become clear was going to
happen how did you scenario plan what
are you trying to
optimize for now
yeah i know and you know when it started
we had early early conversation i was
having discussion with some of our
partners here on the strip and they said
you know hey what are you guys doing for
the coronavirus and and and i
immediately brought my team in and that
was in late february to start putting
and rolling out our emergency management
plan in place um you know as a school
system we always uh dealing with a lot
of different issues
and in my re i recall the day i was a
march 4th
i was up in in carson city in reno for a
discussion uh we're a superintendent
meeting and the the county commission
chair called and and immediately
uh we had our first case and i i can
tell you playing out from that first
case from uh from
you know here in las vegas to some of
the issues that just evolve rather
quickly in matter hours to start
just really calming down the community
and learning and understanding what that
meant for children because obviously the
the first case was an adult but then
it's you know then the quarantine and
getting the
um guidance from the cdc and then really
from the first week um to the first week
and a half is just from learning from
the experts learning from our medical
experts on processes and putting and
enacting our our plan that it seems like
it's been
um six seven months where we're only a
month a month and a week in
um and really preparing for what happens
for school closure and and everything
as a superintendent just evolve and and
and calling and and and working with
some of the
you know the the long-standing
superintendents that have been in this
business to try to understand but this
is unlike any other
unlike any other uh emergency you know
as you mentioned i came from florida and
when we first started you know in really
closing schools for hurricanes right but
there's always that end point and how do
you start your continuity program this
is different this is so different than
preparing for hurricane
or any other disaster this has just been
um
moving and learning
in unchartered waters
but then it the impact that i see here
that i've seen like and unlike any other
work
other place that i've been at it's just
really the impact because our kids
um and our families and then as we shut
down as the governor appreciate you know
that the leadership from the governor's
office to to shut down the entire state
of education
uh all our all our facilities then
within two days all the businesses shut
down so now
um is how do we start going through all
of that uh providing the essentials you
know with our kids that 68 of our
children are on free and reduced lunch
so it was preparing for how are we going
to feed our kids
uh and our family so it just
um to just to back
back pedal uh moving to getting the
essentials the safety first getting them
home
then feeding them and then start moving
into our distance learning education
program
like i said it's been
something that um
it's taken us uh
you know a week or two to start getting
in the group but then
it always continues to evolve and change
and continue to learn and make sure that
our kids are are engaged
oh that's super useful and for those of
y'all listening uh if you're on facebook
or youtube you can put questions in the
message boards we have team members who
are looking at them and i'll try to
surface those to dr jara this is a great
opportunity to ask questions of a
superintendent who's learning running a
very large complex school district if
you're pretty much in any other urban
area the questions that you would ask
your superintendent are just as
applicable as the stuff that dr jarrah
is facing but doctor talk a little bit
about more about that because i think a
lot of for lack of civilians imagine
okay the school district uh they teach
some stuff maybe you have to go online a
little bit but there's all these other
social services that the school district
provides around lunches there's also
questions of equity around internet
access how did that play out with you
and your team especially that first
weekend i remember when it started to
become clear that schools were going to
have to close
yeah no and that was part of we started
preparing for that closure what is that
closure going to look like and then the
team started putting together learning
opportunities so you know so we can have
paper pencil when you look at the
poverty level we are the fifth largest
district we have 320 000 kids 68 of our
free and reduced lunch that means
there's there's that level of poverty
and we did not have a digital one-to-one
device as a school system and as a state
so we had the inequities there as well
so it was whatever learning
opportunities that we're going to put
out there on a paper pencil we're also
going to give give our kids access so
one of the things that we originally
started with it was really the the the
main essentials
you know because as i mentioned our food
insecurity is also very high so bringing
in our our food department our food
service we started with 15
sites in our across our school system
to feed our community to feed our
children to come in and at the same time
as we're doing that then we also put out
our our our learning opportunities not
only on the website but then we made you
know started printing paper copies so
then you were getting a meal and and and
it was just you know watching and seeing
our kids and i visited so many of them
you know our parents were there and our
families and our kids and and one of the
things that was very popular for the
parents was the learning opportunities
the homework you know the homework
package not so popular for our kids
but it was it was really a way to keep
them engaged but their focus was
again the safety and and the mental
health so one of you know we moved into
from 15
very rapidly because we saw the gaps
across our 360 schools we moved now we
currently have 38 different feeding
sites where we continue to have the
package there then we started rolling
out our our our one-to-one devices our
chromebooks that we had in in inventory
uh and and their our first priority was
our high school seniors we wanted to
make sure that our high school seniors
we were not going to
have them suffer their graduation and
their opportunities so we started
deploying chromebooks our pro you know
we're a chromebook
school system so we started deploying
for our high school seniors and then our
credit buried high school students for
those that did not have devices also a
big gap there we had about 64
of our our when look at our inventory 64
of our students who did you know had
devices the other ones did not so you
know immediately reallocated dollars
from the federal government to purchase
devices so we purchased 46 000 devices
that are just coming in now uh moving
rather quickly then we reached out to
our community partners cox communication
um to offer the wi-fi then we bought
some you know moving rather swiftly in
in purchasing the hot spots as well so
we can distribute that again that is all
student driven our principal is doing a
phenomenal job of really working with
our teachers and then our teachers now
starting to for those kids that have the
opportunity for the learning
opportunities
for the teachers to start connecting
with our students online through you
know normal
um you know their their google hangout
and and the google meetup and and some
of those uh platforms that we have
available and then you know in some
cases even phone calls
because again the digital divide for us
was great but i can tell you this
community has stepped up um
significantly to provide opportunities
for our students so those were some of
the most
immediate and now we're now we are
monitoring as a matter of fact that i
you know as as you mentioned we're great
partners uh you know our assessment now
we we we're having deep conversations
internally
is what do we do with now that we have
everything's i think settled
um we look at our our distribution and
instruction principles are now doing
virtual faculty meetings
um you know so a lot of these things
that we're getting into
into a groove even when spring break
this week so which is good it's letting
us catch our breath
to then kick start so now we're looking
at okay what are we gonna do now for the
next six weeks whether we we don't know
um whether we're gonna come back to
school
it's now providing professional
development for professional learning
for our teachers for administrators so
when our kids come back our children
come back to school
is how do we get to close out the year
and then really looking at the data to
start
addressing some of the gaps and and i
know that um you know we're big partners
with with you with khan academy and map
accelerator and also our our nwea
partner so we're looking at how we do
that now to get ready to start um you'll
be proud i'll tell you out of our our
numbers in three through eight
the number i received this morning out
of 165 000 students at that grade level
144
337 have been on map accelerator at
least doing some of that individual
uh
support and really building up you know
from what they they had in their in
their
aligned to their to the rich core on on
maps so we're back growth so we're
really at least excited to see that
there's some engagement at home and i
told the team we need to continue to
push that out um it's not replacing the
teacher but in these times it's giving
us an opportunity for some engagement in
the classroom in in in the online
classroom at school and at home
wow no that's it's incredible what
you're doing i don't think people fully
appreciate what some of what you just
said i just want to underline it i mean
you're thinking about feeding hundreds
of thousands of kids and then you
deploying uh internet access with
devices to
sounds like you know tens of thousands
of households in a matter of days just
that is a major challenge but for where
you're describing that's kind of the
baseline and then then from that you can
build on top of that virtually and for
those of you who aren't familiar with dr
jar is referring to this map accelerator
this is a partnership we've done with
the nwea which is uh they provide the
map growth assessment where that
assessment now acts as a diagnostic as a
placement for work on khan academy and
clark county is actually one of the
first districts that we've partnered
with around this we did a pilot this
past year where uh dr jarrah can see a
dashboard of what's going on
how the kids are using map explorer i'm
really heartened by those numbers and
this is an interesting idea because this
notion of online learning
we've obviously been talking about the
value of it to
let students learn at their own pace
remediate gaps etc before this crisis
but it is interesting how it's evolved
that it's something you could lean on
maybe a little heavier uh when when
we're in a crisis situation like this
i i'm getting a lot of questions here uh
let's see from
from
youtube uh craig yen
asks how are you supporting your
teachers with distant with distant
learning
yeah no that's a great question and
that's one of the things that you know
we again moving quickly
into uh in a week or so into a digital
learning platform for teachers and
that's one of the things that i just had
a great conversation this morning with
the team
is is to now so continue to support our
teachers and and what does that look
like so we're putting together a a
learning plan uh you know for for the
next six weeks and then for the summer
you know we haven't done that in the
past as an entire system so it's
something that now um in in
conversations with the department of
education here in the state of nevada is
where we're going to put together some
of our experts
and across the state and start providing
using using another platform canvas to
then provide some content for our
teachers and then also um looking at
some of these model lessons as well one
of the things that we're going to start
requesting from our teachers is to um
you know start sharing some of their
lessons so that we can then put them on
a platform for others at the school
level our principals have done a great
job and really doing some plc's that's
all online doing some plc
uh professional work plc standpoint
yeah professional learning communities
uh within our within their grade level
and specific to the schools led by the
administrators or their content experts
at the school so that that's happening
at individualized school level and then
obviously uh for providing support for
the teachers
um as well uh you know during their
weekly faculty meeting one of the one of
the other aspects that we're now as
we're looking at is the analyzing the
use of data so we're going to start
taking that time to do that now um as
we're closing out the year
yeah and i have two related questions
i'll i'll combine them uh one from
facebook rebecca nelson says do you
foresee clark county embracing distance
learning for next school year even if
the kids are able to return to school
maybe modify that as online learning or
some permutation how is the distance
learning changing the mindset of
educators and then related to that on
scott yang is asking on facebook dr
jarrah do you think school can resume
normally how do you think school will
resume
yeah those are two great questions and
that's where we've been we're
challenging ourselves i mean you know
because we're thinking our kids are
going to come back they're going to
enjoy
um you know this this new
way of learning so i've challenged the
team as we move forward to look at how
we're going to capitalize on where we
are to provide opportunities for
distance learning so it's a conversation
we're having i think i think as a
district is is stretched us um
our mindset to then start moving forward
um to provide different opportunities so
um do i predict it's going to be a lot
different i believe i believe it is and
and we're going to have to evolve and
move quickly to be able to get to that
so
um you know it's going to be different
and maybe project more project based and
and these are the conversations that
we're having now as a team for for the
next year
and are there conversations happening or
is it just you know too far ahead are
people talking about what if the virus
picks back up in the fall or
uh you know we loosen social distancing
and it picks back up how are y'all
thinking about that or is that just too
far out right now well
you know sally this is why i love you
pushed me to think all the time we were
thinking that uh we may come back to
school when we come back to school in
august when we do that um we weren't
thinking about you know having to come
back it's it's a it's a it's um
it's a good question to ask uh we're
thinking that once we come back when
it's safe we'll just start over uh it's
just gonna be different and innovative
and i think that's that's where we are
but uh you know we'll just at least now
as i say to the team we we know how to
shut down a school district uh rather
quickly we can start it back up but uh
uh not yet not not yet us to to coming
back and and having to close again
because of the virus
yeah and i can't imagine the complexity
you you have to deal with on a
day-to-day basis much less through
through a practice like this
so we have relate you know you touched
on a little bit but there's two
questions and this is a question i've
been getting a lot too and i am curious
to get more depth from youtube username
july is asking how can you make sure
that all kids in your district have a
chance to learn online do they have
necessary equipment like laptops tablet
or internet and then from youtube
sixtist106 asks dr jarrah are you doing
what are you doing to support kids who
don't have internet you mentioned a
little bit this rollout of chromebooks
you've got more chromebooks or devices
you're trying to where are we you know
do all of your kids now have access or
there's still a subset that don't and
how are you handling that
so that our first week when we took
attendance our first week which was uh
three weeks ago we have 21 you know
we're still looking for 20 back then
march march 23rd through the 27th
you know only we're missing 21 of our
students that we had not been able to
contact so now it's now we're putting
our social services we're putting our
social workers we're putting call outs
into the community if you have not heard
from us at least back then is that you
need to contact the school and continue
that conversation as we continue to take
attendance um you know there's the
there's still the huge digital divide
that we have and we started we have our
public ed foundation as well that has in
our community very giving community that
has um you know started a campaign to to
raise money
for us not only for the device but for
the hot spots but also for the
professional learning for the students
for the parents and for our teachers so
it's a work in progress to be quite
candid with you
and and related to that we have a bunch
of questions about the remainder of the
year facebook yolanda brunez facebook
denise puckett on youtube lyanna garcia
crespo they're all asking some version
of uh is
it for sure that schools are going to be
remain closed through the end of the
year and then a related question from
facebook tammy harveston is asking will
graduations be cancelled or postponed
yeah
so uh you know we're waiting when when
the governor closed the school it was uh
you know it'll be depending if we open
it will be depending on the state chief
health officer to make that
determination we've seen others across
the country that have made the decisions
not to reopen
so it's a wait and see
so we don't have that information i've
asked for at least a week lead time for
us to be able to to reopen it just
depends on where we are as a matter of
fact having conversations this morning
with the team and i'm i'm calling in
next wednesday i will be meeting
virtually with all our senior uh class
presidents from our from our schools all
our we got 49 high schools uh to get
ideas because you know we have some
ideas about how we do graduation
graduations in may i don't foresee that
because
our partner university of north los
university of nevada las vegas here uh
unlv is where we host and they're closed
and they've canceled their graduation
postponed them
so we don't have uh the facility so
we're gonna call out our
our seniors i am to talk to them and and
get some ideas from them uh because my
greatest idea is not you know i'm not at
their appropriate age group uh so i'm
gonna get some of their ideas to see how
we do this
yeah and what about credit generally is
it still kind of a work in progress
things like grades is there a way that
it don't have a point of view on that
yet
we do uh the state just released some
guidance and and working with all
superintendents so we're working
together uh we're going to our third
marking period we opened up you know
which is right it closed as soon as we
were finishing and we ended up closing
school so we've opened up the third
market period for our all our high
schools and our schools for credit
bearing and and across the board
secondary schools as well uh for
students to make up
any any uh assignments that you know
that they missed or or wanted to redo so
so that's that's available uh you know
and then now we're having the
conversations about what we do for
fourth for the fourth marking period and
graduation requirements the state has
left it up to us so next week we'll be
you know meeting with our senior high
school principals and and put some some
of those requirements out um for our our
high school seniors you know and then
and then also having conversations with
our higher ed partners because i didn't
want our students because of this
because of this pandemic to be
you know penalized for gpa and
scholarship opportunities so so we're
looking and we're always going to decide
on on behal on on the side of the
students it's not their fault and and
necessarily something is something that
we need to find ways to address and help
them
yeah
and
related to everything we're talking
about really from youtube ashitosh
tawari is asking how do you think the
education curriculum in syllabus will i
think he's saying catch up after covet
19. he's you know referring to this
issue of normally you have a summer
slide three months of not only going to
school but potentially for getting or
lost now you have five months we've seen
some data that that might lead if kids
aren't engaged over that five months to
as much as a year of of lost learning so
kids are going to come at the beginning
with even bigger gaps bigger variation
are y'all
what's your thinking there
yeah no that's a great um great question
and and great comment um i know the data
was released uh nwa released their data
this morning uh on their covet slide
cover 19 slide which is startling i i've
been on the phone i was with them on the
phone yesterday so so um and last week
with chris minnick uh one and his team
one of the things that we're looking at
is to prepare for the restart
and using some of the federal stimulus
dollars that are coming in which is
going to be very helpful um is it going
to be you know so the team is looking at
the
standards that we've missed in this
marking period to then how do we embed
them in the in the first in the first
semester is it just extending the longer
extending the day um you know
it's it's it's opportunities in the
summer so so we'll have a plan in place
in in the coming week uh on what we're
going to be able to do for our students
to catch them up because it really is
startling and and and you know
uh
when the data when i looked at it and
and the pushback not a pushback i think
it was really when i looked at the data
on the average student um from nwa and
and i think
the equity gaps and that's what that's
what keeps me up at night because i
think when you look at the equity gaps
uh for our children and living in
poverty are english language learners i
think it's going to be a greater slide
for them
yeah just want you to know you're
getting a lot of very positive feedback
from from several folks on youtube on
facebook on facebook shelly shellyfox
said i love that you're reaching out to
seniors for input and ideas thank you
for your leadership and then from uh
youtube beautiful bex wrote i think it's
amazing how he's getting student input
for the seniors i hope my school does
that so a lot a lot of kudos there dr
dara well thank you
and and so there's another question here
let me see if i can find it again it was
about it was a it sounds like a parent
oh there you go uh from youtube jen
mills and this is a question i've been
getting a lot although i have very
little expertise here how are you
handling special education my son is
autistic and our district is not
organized how are y'all thinking about
that
well you know and and now just to defend
of the district i think
there was a lot of different information
coming
to us early uh from the u.s department
of education and it was just really
moving very very swiftly and changing
so my team
did a great job in working with the
council of great city schools we put a
document together it's really um you
know we're using
the virtual world
obviously because we i as we said we
have a stem home order
um so our our special special education
educators are reaching out through
whether they have um
you know
google meets or whether it's a video
conferencing or if not there's no
technologies a phone call video
conferencing to provide the services uh
i'll be honest some of the some of the
bigger challenges that we're seeing is
you know when we have the you know we
can do
the support there from our teachers and
and um in our support staff that helps
our kids one of the biggest challenges
that we're seeing is is when we have the
the occupational therapy and the
physical therapy we have to put our
hands on our students so that's one of
the things that we're being challenged
um so i don't i i wanna you know really
for for the school system wherever you
are um it's just been a moving target
and a challenge for us as well
yeah no that's i i could imagine this so
there's so many questions uh we're gonna
have to have you on again soon uh but
maybe to close out i'll you know there's
a lot of doom and gloom out in the world
today and a lot of unanswered questions
uh but you kind of hinted at it you know
maybe there's silver linings that as we
go through this very sub-optimal
situation there might be things that we
come out maybe better for or different
at least um curious to get your thoughts
you know what what's your what's your
message for for any uh uh parents and
teachers and students listening from
clark county or or or as a proxy for for
other people's superintendents what
would you like to tell them
well you know i just said be patient uh
which is a message i uh i've shared with
our community cell and and everyone just
be patient this is unprecedented times
we don't know and we're gonna make
mistakes it's hard uh you know as i i'll
tell you as i as i do and and and hope
and i know my my colleague
superintendent they're going to make the
best decisions that
that they think is the right decision on
behalf of their families and students um
so just be a little patient it's hard
work uh
as as i see the future i think this
has gonna force us to say you know
education is gonna look different uh
what different what that looks like i
don't know uh our teachers are i'll tell
you um our hard-working teachers and i
think our teachers our educators
have jumped right in and and and on
behalf of our kids um trying to do the
best they can so um you know looking
forward to the future and what that
looks like uh we don't know what that is
but it'll be it'll be exciting for our
kids you know that's the silver lining
as i see it
yeah well well dr jar as always it's uh
great to talk to you it's an honor to
have you all as one of our close
partners at khan academy and stay safe
and healthy and keep doing your great
work
i will thank you sal i appreciate it
thanks for having me
thank you
thank you well everyone uh i thought
that was a
super valuable update from from dr jara
i just want to thank all of y'all for
joining uh we hope to continue to do
this throughout the closures and maybe
beyond every day keep your questions
coming and i'll just give another
reminder we are not for profit if you're
in a position to do so please think
about donating to khan academy there's a
there's url someplace on the screen khan
academy.org
donate and i'll also say just speaking
as you know one human being to another
uh you know whenever i meet folks like
dr jara and we had david coleman on a
couple of days ago and bill gates a
couple of days before that you just see
how a lot of folks are are stepping up
and doing what they can and you know as
hard as the situation is i've been
seeing a lot of kind of the best of
humanity step up and we're all going
through this together and
it's it's it's great to be able to
connect with you all in this way and
hopefully it's making you feel a little
less socially distanced uh it's
definitely helping me with that and and
so with that i will see you all all
tomorrow
you